- Welcome to the second of two
Franke Visiting Fellow lectures,
our opportunity to share with
the larger Yale community
work in progress by Alejandra Oliva.
Before I introduce Alejandra,
I'd like to say a few
words about Richard Franke
whose generosity has brought
Alejandra to Yale this year
and who died last Friday.
Richard's contributions to
the Whitney Humanities Center
and its programs have and will
continue to lift our spirits
and nourish our minds.
He provided both the
inspiration and the endowments
for the Franke Lectures and
Seminars in the Humanities,
the Franke Program in
Science and Humanities,
and the Franke Visiting Fellows Program.
Since 2005, the Franke Visiting Fellows
have served as catalysts
for intellectual gatherings
at the Whitney Humanities
Center setting their own agendas
and presenting their
work to the community.
Their presence ensures ongoing
interdisciplinary exchange
and creative debate at
the Whitney in particular,
and at Yale in general.
Franke Visiting Fellows
are an integral part
of the Whitney Fellowship.
And this year I've been
especially grateful
to James McAuley and Alejandra Oliva
for their supportive presence
in our Wednesday Whitney's
Humanities Center Fellows Forums.
One final word about Rich Franke,
his New York Times obituary
in yesterday's paper
suggests donations to a
cause that was dear to him,
support for immigrants and refugees,
specifically Integrated Refugee
and Immigration Services
in New Haven, IRIS.
Thinking of Rich Franke today,
it brings me great pleasure
to be introducing someone
whose life work centers on immigration
and who does that work in Chicago,
the city where the Frankes made their home
for most of their lives.
I'm delighted then to
introduce Alejandra Oliva.
Since she's come to the Whitney,
Alejandra has completed the manuscript
of her much anticipated
book "River Mouth,"
which her publisher has
described beautifully as, quote,
an urgent reckoning and reexamination
of the humanitarian crisis
we call the American immigration system
based on her work as a
translator for asylum seekers.
Her experiences with borders and asylum
include her time following
a migrant caravan
and helping families cross over
from Tijuana into California,
which she described in
an award-winning essay,
at the border no one can know your name.
She can also testify to
her work as an interviewer
at an immigrant detention center
attached to a private prison
in the State of Mississippi.
Alejandra brings to all
her work her unique talents
as a poet, an essayist, a
translator, a textile artist,
a theorist of social justice
and language justice.
Her trajectory is as
intentional and creative
as her artwork.
After an undergraduate degree at Columbia,
she began working with a
new sanctuary coalition
as a volunteer interpreter and
translator in asylum clinics.
She took a master's degree at
the Harvard Divinity School
where she honed her thinking
about social justice
reading Oscar Romero and
Valeria Luiselli among others.
The day we discussed
the poster for her talk,
I learned something precious
from her about writing.
She chose to illustrate this lecture,
and you can see the poster over there,
with a work of embroidery she created
at the very worst moment of the lockdown.
Growing beans in her apartment,
sitting in for a long haul,
she decided to sew
individual beans in a pattern
onto the center of a cloth.
And if you look very
closely at the photograph,
you can see the threads
pushed through the beans with a needle,
an arduous process.
She surrounded the
beans with stitched fans
inspired by the work
of one of her favorite
Mexican textile artists,
Gabriela Martinez Ortiz.
Two textures, two substances in harmony.
I learned that there's
a link for Alejandra
between putting words
on a page and stitching,
both involve minute
attention, repeated gestures,
both are born of a mind
clearing away distractions
and paying attention to detail.
Strength of imagination goes hand in hand
for Alejandra Oliva
with strength of purpose
in the public sphere.
She has worked since 2019 as
the communications coordinator
for the National Immigrant
Justice Center in Chicago,
which provides direct services,
state and national advocacy,
and information to media
who are covering exceptionally troubled
and troubling immigration policy.
We're honored at the Whitney
to have given her space
to write about this important work.
Her lecture is entitled
You Can't Translate What You Can't See:
Between Languages in the
U.S. Immigration System.
Please join me in welcoming Alejandra.
(audience applauding)
- Thank you so, so much Alice
for that incredibly lovely introduction
and thank you so much to the
Whitney Humanities Center
and Mr. and Mrs. Richard Franke
for giving me this incredible gift of time
and resources to work on my book.
I was so sorry to hear of
the passing of Mr. Franke,
may his memory and his
legacy be a blessing.
Thank you also to all of
you that are here today,
particularly my family and my friends
who have traveled to be here.
I'm incredibly excited to
be with you this afternoon
and to talk to you a little bit
about what I've been working
on during my time here.
As Alice mentioned, I'm a translator.
I have translated for people
who are filling out asylum applications
in the basement of a church
at the US-Mexico border in Tijuana
for people who are waiting to cross,
for the lucky few who
emerged on the other side
of harrowing legal journeys
who want to tell a journalist
about what happened to them.
I've observed translation
happening over language line,
a telephonic translation service,
in immigration courtrooms in Boston
for people appearing in
court over video link.
I've witnessed the effects
of a lack of language support
for immigrants incarcerated at
a prison owned by core civic
in a small town in Mississippi.
I've also done translation
in the ways that many of
you have experienced it,
behind a computer screen with a beloved,
or a complicated or exciting
text open in one window,
a word document in another.
Today, I want to talk about
both of these kinds of translation
and the way that they
sit next to each other
and influence each other.
I think it's also important to note
that I haven't really gotten
any training as a translator
or an interpreter nor
am I really an academic.
I'd like to think that I've
done a fair amount of reading
in the field of translation studies
and that my near daily practice
of translation and interpretation
have really helped me sort
through what I've read
to find and embrace what feels true.
But I also know that
I'm not really engaged
with the ways in which
the academic community
has been thinking and
talking about translation.
Because of that I'm not sure how
or whether my project really speaks
to more contemporary
conversations about translation
and translation theory,
but I'm really looking
forward to your feedback
and questions at the end of the talk.
When you're translating,
you're constrained
by what you can see on the page.
If you miss the way
the two words flow
sibilantly into one another
or you don't know the
meaning of an aphorism,
then they don't turn up
in the version of the text
you create as you translate,
or if they do, it's a lucky accident.
A sentence carefully crafted
for the way it sounds
read aloud falls flat.
The sky literally begins
to rain, cats, and dogs.
This kind of mistake is
invisible to most readers
who will never read both the
original and the translation
who probably don't know
enough of the source language
to clock a slobby translated Axiom.
However, this is also the kind of mistake
that might keep you up
at night as a translator.
What injustice did you do to the original?
What nuances in the
text does your audience
have no hope of grasping
because you missed it?
Something similar happens
with the kind of writing I do.
My work sits somewhere
between journalism and memoir.
It's largely based on my own experiences,
but it's bolstered by research,
by going out into the field,
by meeting people, by talking to people,
this is to some extent
translating the real world into language.
I can't really write
something I haven't seen
or lived through.
I've tried, I'm not that good at it,
but I also can't transmit
the entire of reality to you
on the page because I can't see it all.
Things by necessity will
slip through the cracks.
The possibility for this kind
of misreading or blindness
also keeps me up at night.
Am I doing the stories I tell justice?
Am I is the context that
you then will also miss?
The stories we tell ourselves,
the stories we receive
culturally also work as blinders,
giving us quick mental
shortcuts to a misconception
or letting us take the
way out of the story
that makes us feel the least bad.
We prefer to gloss over complexity
in preference of a simple story,
easy to tell and
understand and respond to.
These stories are the equivalent
of a word for word translation.
They help you get a general
shape down on paper,
but otherwise they're oddly constructed
and ungainly they're easily misunderstood
and they fall apart under
any kind of closer scrutiny.
So much of our current immigration system,
the stories in the media,
the laws that are written are meant to be
like these word for word translations.
They supply us with the easy
stories, the bad humbres,
the children in cages and through them
are erased legions of other stories.
Thousands of other contexts
and individual lives
are papered over or
omitted from the record
in favor of the easy story.
It is not hard to be moved
to emotion and action
by these stories to anger,
to grief or fear to protest.
But it's just as important
to keep paying attention
even as the big stories run out,
even as the narratives
unspool into a gray area.
The very existence of the
immigration laws we have today
is proof of this.
Our asylum laws specifically
were created to respond
to a single story and for
narratives outside of that,
the aid we can offer is hams
by the laws were governed by.
Our concept of asylum on an
international level is based on
ideas about religious and
ethnic persecution that began
during the Holocaust
and are narrowly crafted
to prevent another genocide and just that.
During the Second World War
national immigration quotas
based themselves on a
story about other nations
overrunning the United States
with floods of immigrants
kept the Ms St. Louis
floating off the coast
of the United States
full of German Jewish refugees
who couldn't claim a formal
kind of immigration assistance.
Even as the ship floated
close enough to the shore
for the passengers to hear the
music from Miami nightclubs,
even as Americans argued
that those on board
should be admitted to the US,
our laws made no space for the
passengers of the St. Louis
to be granted entry
into the United States.
The St. Louis eventually turned around
and docked again in Europe
resulting in the murder of
a quarter of its passengers
in Nazi death camps.
In response to that great horror,
we have expanded our story
about immigration once
and we need to expand it again today.
To gain asylum, you have to convince
the United States government
that you have a credible fear
of returning to your home country
because you are or have been
persecuted by your government
or an entity, it is
unwilling or unable to stop
and that this persecution happened
because you are a member of
a particular social group,
a characteristic of
yourself that you are unable
or should not be forced to
change your political opinion,
your religion, your sexuality,
your ethnicity, your race, your gender.
Our immigration laws and the
story that has inspired them
since the '50s, keep us from
helping the man from Haiti
who is legitimately
afraid of returning home
because of rising sea levels
and a lack of local infrastructure.
The United Nations has
predicted that by 2050,
between 25 million and a
billion people worldwide
will be climate refugees
displaced by droughts,
floods, fires, and rising seas.
Our immigration laws
forces to treat the man
with a possession charge who
has been in the United States
his whole life differently
than the a man with a possession charge
who arrived when he was a year old,
both get a few months, a
couple years in prison.
But at the end of that time,
we tell one of them that he
has paid his debt to society
and is able to go home
while the other is
incarcerated for even longer,
separated from his family and community
and ultimately sent to a
strange country he barely knows.
Today's immigration laws
asked us to pretend that
border cities are safe places
for people waiting to enter the country
even as the state department
issues travel advisories
warning US citizens to stay away,
ask us to ignore violence against people
unless it happens under
deeply specific circumstances,
ask us to formulaically and
easily refuse help to those
who were me to actually
listen to their stories
we would extend a hand to.
What I'm getting at is this,
you make a personal ethics,
you make laws the same
way you translate a text,
the same way you write a book,
you look at the world around you
and there are things you notice
and there are things you don't.
There's the short version of the story
that you're able to receive and
1,000 longer ones you don't.
There's the short, sorry.
If you're lucky you read
the words of other people
who have looked out on
the world before you,
who have caught other
things that you didn't,
and you change your mind,
you change your actions,
you start seeing things you
had been blind to before.
There are many things that
because of the family,
the place in society that I was born into,
I had the luxury of learning slowly,
of learning only intellectually
and never emotionally
until someone who had
learned them the hard way
was kind enough to show me.
There are other things,
other experiences that I know
people to be blind to, that
I felt down to my bones.
The thing I've been
writing and thinking about
for the last five years
and more concretely
in the last few months here
at Yale is yes, immigration,
yes, translation.
But it's also reading and rereading,
going over passages in your life,
pouring over someone else's words
until you find your own
life irrevocably altered.
Today, I want to talk to you
about the way this happened
in my own life.
It starts with translation
and it starts with the two
languages I was raised in.
What can I tell you about
growing up in two languages?
the that Spanish folded me
into my family, the house I grew up in?
What can I tell you about
how English gave me access
to the world outside my house,
allowed me to have a different vocabulary
to talk about who I am?
Most of my life is conducted in English,
that's the language I use to
think, read, write, argue,
calculate tips, chat, swear, name myself.
But still whenever I hear
Spanish on the street,
especially a strong Mexican Spanish,
a feeling of tenderness of
family springs up inside me,
this more than anything
means family to me.
Even though so much of my life
happens in another language,
this well of feeling that Spanish uncovers
means that my life lived only in English
would be incomplete.
Growing up we never really lived anywhere
with big communities of Mexican
families, or if there were,
we weren't really part of them.
My Spanish was not the
Spanish of backyard barbecues
or entire weekend spent together
with a herd of other children, my age,
or the Spanish of telling secrets
under the covers at late night sleepovers,
it was the Spanish of
deep jokes of my parents
in 1980 slang, all cleaned up for us.
The Spanish Guadalupe Pineda and Cri-Cri.
Translation was a way, the only way
in which Spanish became social.
It allowed me to reach beyond
the boundaries of my family.
I marked the beginning of
my work as a translator
to January of 2017,
the first week of the
Trump administration.
Like a lot of other people,
I had found myself at odds
with everything that week,
strange and restless and anxious.
And so when a friend
offered me the opportunity
to translate for asylum seekers
at a weekly Pro Se Clinic,
I said, yes, immediately.
This is how I found myself
sitting in a church basement,
just off Washington Square Park
with a couple of other volunteers
across the table from a woman
who has only been in the United States
for about three weeks,
let's call her Myra.
I'm not actually going to be
telling you the real names
or stories of anyone that I've talked to
because that's their stories and not mine,
but also not giving you a
name or a face to the people
that I've met is one of the
reasons that it's so easy
to discard the stories we hear.
So for now, for this talk,
Myra exists, she has a name,
She's a real person I
spent an afternoon with.
Her story is not dissimilar
to those of many people I've worked with
and she's sitting across the table from me
a week after Trump took office.
Between us was an I-589 form known as
the application for asylum
and withholding of removal.
And it would be our job
together over the next few hours
to fill out that form and
petition the government
so that she could stay in United States.
The question of where Myra
will be allowed to call home
is so critical because the answer
is a matter of life or death.
Back in Honduras where she
had lived her whole life
up until a few weeks
ago, her brother was shot
in front of her and the guy who did it
told her that she would be next.
The asylum application is her best shot
at convincing the US
government that her survival
is dependent on her being
able to stay in the country.
Even though we're here around this table,
ready to fill out this
application together,
all of us, which we did not have to be,
Myra I'm sure wishes that this translation
we were working on was unnecessary.
She would rather, her life had continued
on its familiar way, her brother alive,
her family together in on Honduras.
And I assume the other of
a volunteers here with us
wish that Myra's presence in this country
was not to some extent contingent
on the strength of my
translation on the tear jerkiness
or trauma of Myra's story.
The US government based on
this form appears to wish
Myra was not here at all
and yet here we all are,
Myra, all of us volunteers
and the US government
collaborators on this translation
that no one really wants.
My job sitting across the table from Myra
is to let her talk, to
ask clarifying questions
and see if through the interview
new information can be shaken loose,
placed in a chronic logical order to form
a cohesive narrative
with call as an effect.
My job is also to take her
words and carry them across
from the Spanish she has spoken
her entire life into English,
the language spoken by most
people in the United States
and critically the language spoken by
the government officials
at the United States
citizenship and immigration
services that will read
and judge her application.
I'm particularly well suited
to the task of not uniquely,
so I've spoken both English
and Spanish, my entire life,
my childhood echoing with
parental admonishments
to repeat what I'm saying in Espanol.
Spanish was a language for
home for family, for affection
and love and closeness and
English was the language
of the outside world of many
of the books I read, of school.
Growing up in a relatively wealthy family
as the US-Citizen daughter
of Mexican immigrants,
I given my languages in the same way
as I was given my
citizenships as a birthrights,
motherlands and mother tongues at once.
In my interactions with people that
were working towards both
Americanness and English,
I came to see the outlines
of both as artificial.
In context where everything was being done
to divide me politically from
the people I was speaking to,
it was our shared language
that allowed us to find shared ground.
It was in doing the work,
the translation and the interpretation,
but most importantly, the
listening that my world shifted,
the political, moral, emotional
category that encompassed me
and my family and the people
I loved grew and expanded,
not just in name or in
ideals, but in actual fact.
Translation for asylum seekers
was the thing that finished
transforming my tongue
into a political actor,
finished bridging the
divide between the Spanish,
inside my head and the Spanish
in the rest of the world.
Spanish, the language of my
family allowed me to feel my way
into a kind of intimacy with people
I knew very little about
allowed me to be useful agent
in a way I didn't know how to imagine.
It allowed me to take a thing,
a language of vocabulary,
a way of speaking,
that was the province
of my safe childhood.
And to try to extend it
like a protective mantle
over the people who wanted the
same for their own children.
The translation with
Myra was the first time
I was really able to do that,
but it also immediately became
clear that our conversation
would not be protective.
It would not be a matter
of safety or care or love.
If you're not familiar with the I-589 form
an asylum seeker must fill out,
the bulk of the form consists in detailing
whatever traumatic event
has sent someone fleeing
from their country and
answering why they believe
that event came looking
for them specifically.
As each of the forms, awful,
stilted did questions land.
I watch as Myra shrinks
farther and farther
back in her chair,
her eyes more often seeking
out the corners of the room,
her sleeve in danger
of being picked apart.
I offer tissues even though
she's dry eyed water,
even though her voice doesn't crack,
a break even though when I ask,
she looks at me with
a grim set to her jaw,
shakes her head no and so we keep going.
As I talk to her,
I'm also talking to the
two other volunteers
around the table with us
explaining to them in my own voice,
in my own words, what Myra is telling me
and they're writing it down.
So the ways in which I'm hurting Myra,
by asking her to remember,
do not go to waste.
I take her words and I translate them,
I carry them across into the
language of her new country.
Translation comes from
the Latin translatus,
to carry across.
The word itself, implies
an edge, a dividing line.
To translate means to
carry across languages
across borders, across cultures.
Translation is also something
we do with our body,
something that lives in our blood.
We move through our mother
tongue into that of a new home,
we sense the right word or phrase
with the kind of bodily and
tuition where shades of meaning
an imprecise logic dwell.
In his book, "Translator's
Turn" Douglas Robinson
posits a theory of
translation that is visceral,
that involves gut
feelings and clammy palms,
sense residing, not in
cognition, but in sensation.
I have found this to be true.
Our bodies remember the specific
flavor of words in two languages.
The taste of the edge
between two ways of saying.
As the word implies we also
use our bodies to carry meaning
from one language to another.
It's impossible not to feel
what I'm translating inside my body,
impossible not to carry it with me
from a church basement or a
plaza after I hang up the phone
damp and hot from being pressed
next to my ear for an hour.
So much of translation and interpretation
requires me to pass
someone else's language
through the first person.
Their eyes becomes my own,
their injuries and experiences
enter language that for all
that I'm trying to render
faithfully as theirs is
in reality only mine.
This line of self and not self
is like chalk on a Blackboard.
From far away the line looks crisp, stark,
easy to understand,
but as you approach it,
as your nose bumps the dust slate,
you understand that the line
is not exactly unbroken,
that no matter how much you erase,
the particles of the
chalk that wear that line
still float through the air.
When you translate, it becomes
clear that to be entangled
with someone's language is
to be entangled in them,
in their histories and idiosyncrasies.
To translate is to be in
community with someone.
This is in part because
language is something
we construct together across countries
and continents and centuries,
as much as within communities
and conversations.
There is no expression, no
understanding without the other
to express or to understand.
When I speak Spanish,
I'm speaking the language of
Hernan Cortes and La Malinche,
Sor Juana and Gioconda
Belli, Servantis and Marquez.
It's also my own language,
the words taught to me by my mother
when I was just learning
to ask for what I wanted,
the made up language composed
of malapropisms of mine
and my siblings as we
were learning to talk,
the borrowed words from English,
the patterns of sentences
I unknowingly absorbed from
my parents' ways of speaking
and made my own.
This language is the water I stand in,
the well I draw from.
There are tributaries
feeding my spot in the river,
both above and below the earth.
This same river, a little further upstream
is the one the 17th century poet nun,
Sor Juana Ines de la Cruz drew from.
And when I say the word
muher or the word fe,
these are words that have
been fundamentally altered
by her having written about
them some 300 years ago.
The Spanish she wrote in turn
was influenced by her time
in the viceroy's court,
as a lady in waiting
as it was by the Nahuatl she learned
from her mother's
household staff as a child.
As influenced by the
Spanish of Hernan Cortes
who had first come to Mexico
just 129 years before her birth.
As by the language of Malinche,
the Nahua woman who
served as his interpreter
and the mother of one of his children.
This was the water Sor Juana drew from
and what she returned to the river
was forever altered by having
passed through her hands.
When I speak or write,
my words flew out from my own little Eddie
to rejoin the wider stream.
My turns of phrase become
part of the Spanish
that exists in the world
just as Sor Juana's did,
able to be picked up and passed around,
drawn up to drink and to be
appropriated by another waiter.
In this way language is
made up of the personal
and the cumulative.
Each of us standing in our own space,
absorbing the words around us
and contributing to the greater stream.
Like the waters of the river,
it's an inevitable inseparable
commingling of the collective
and the individual.
Language would not work
if we could not share it,
but the individual impressions we leave
and the baggage we bring with us
on each word we say matter too.
We should also talk a
little bit about the baggage
that the translation
in and of itself brings
particularly here in the West.
A lot of the earliest questions
in translation studies
are ultimately biblical
translation theory.
This is why even when you're
not necessarily talking about
the word of God, the original
is held up as this bright
and viable that the translator
must struggle to approach
much less replicate.
To find the source of this brightness,
theorists keep pointing, not
just behind the original text,
but behind language itself.
Walter Benjamin, who is deeply concerned
with the idea of God's
language in his essay,
"The Task of the Translator,"
describes a good translation
as one that is transparent
so that it, quote,
does not cover up the original,
does not block its light,
but allows the pure language
to shine upon the original all the more.
He gestures not only at
the pure language of able
and the Bible, but to the threshold space
that translation occupies
the way it needs to both exist and not.
There's a sense in which
looking at any original
in the light of divine
origination makes total sense.
The creation of any text is
a miracle of individuation,
of reference and self-reference
of idiosyncratic experiences
just as miraculous
as the idea of an
individual consciousness.
When you're translating literary text,
there's a kind of slow awareness of this
as you find your sentences
unfurling along paths
that are not your usual,
a different understanding
of the creator of the text.
When you become aware that
this author, your author,
uses the word, the word
querto, the word casa,
the word plata, like no
one ever has or will again,
you also realize that you can
only ever know a part of it,
you can only skim the
surface of their meaning,
the dizzy individuality of
any single writer or mind
multiplied by all the
possible writers and minds,
or even your own as you read
or turn unfolds into a world
that feels as intricate
as God's fingerprint.
My investment in this
idea however stops short
when I think of my other source text,
which are not usually the
product of slow mornings
sitting at your desk, or
even the stress and pressure
of looming deadlines,
but rather the product
of extreme violence and fear created
not to serve a creative desire,
but rather to fill a bureaucrats form.
I don't like the implication
that there's something holy
about suffering that's present
in so much of Christian philosophy
and often gets carried over
into translation theory.
I hate the idea that there's
a pure and shining light
at the back of any of the
pain I've born witness to.
None of it feels like
what I want God to be.
I don't want to honor the
original don't want to revere it
like I might the words from God's mouth.
On the other hand, I also
don't want to mutilate
the stories I'm given like I do every time
I fill out an asylum application,
it feels sacrilegious
to cut up someone's life
in the interest of the government
because there's something
of value in someone's story.
Something that deserves careful treatment,
deserves to be honored and respected
and not prized out with
priors and smashed up.
This something isn't about the divinity
or the fore ordination of any story
or the sacredness of the
idea of stories in general,
or about the beauty of suffering.
But because the people telling them
are viscerally embodied human.
As I'm reminded with every
tissue or glass of water,
these stories are important
because the person sitting in front of me
and I share the fragility of our flesh
and are entrusted to one another
because of the thinness of our skins,
the delicate workings of our insides.
At the same time our
bodies are not enough.
The asylum application is a skeleton that,
like the worst be movie
cliche longs for a body.
The asylum system is hungry
for bodies, bodies to suffer,
bodies to fill up beds in
for profit detention centers,
bodies to work in the fields and factories
and behind the scenes of everything,
all the while rejecting their humanity.
The I-589 pretends to
care about biography,
asks for a narrative in a
specific person's voice.
But in reality is only concerned
with the violence on the body,
glancing off anything
deeper than the skin.
A bad translation does the same work,
it lives on the surface of the text,
it's concerned with a physical
shape, the surface meaning,
whatever reflection
momentarily blinds you.
A good translation drives
somewhere to the beating heart of a text.
You can only translate what you can see
and if all that is visible
to you is a somebody,
if all that is presented is the surface,
then there's something about the human
that's still invisible to
you, to the government,
to the immigration judge in his chambers
and the CBP patrolman in his truck.
The people I translate for are
survivors among generations
of the sabatassidos, the farmers with land
not yet seized or made barren
by multinational corporations,
the people who are in a out
left to die in the desert
or dumped into mass graves in the sea
or corralled into camps to die of neglect.
The compassino no one bothered to bribe.
The United States has been deeply involved
in Central and South America for decades.
Behind every revolution,
every uprising coup of the 20th century,
there were CIA agents or Congressmen
making colonial decisions to
stop the spread of communism
or more commonly to protect US
investments and corporations.
The translation I take part in
is the meagres form of reparations
and has more to do with the
CIA agents and the Congressman
than the utopian promise
that more contemporary
translators make for us.
Like the United States, which
welcomed European immigrants
as low level workers with
a plea for the world's
tired and hungry, which builds
itself as a great melting pot
with fine words about
the equality of all men,
translation likes to describe
itself as a diplomat,
bridging cultures, or as a bridge itself
spanning the Rio Grande,
the kind of thing that
can transcend borders,
but ignoring the ways
power can come through
and across that bridge, the
way a diplomat always, always
has his own nation's
best interests at heart,
you become complicit in this power.
When I translate for an
asylum seeker like Myra,
I like to think I'm working
against the powers that be,
but the truth is I'm filling out the form.
I'm making people findable,
searchable, cross indexable
for a government that has
proven time and time again,
that the only way in which
it cares about these lives
is as resources to be
extracted to exhaustion.
I don't know how else to help.
I don't know if I'm brave
or smart or strong enough
to find another way to wipe
away the fear of separation,
the fear of return, to remake
the world into the place
it needs to be to make
sure everyone is safe.
I don't even know if bravery
or smarts or strength
on an individual or an
even collective level
are capable of fixing this problem.
Instead, what I have
is this government form
and a little while to spend
across the table from Myra
and the ability to make her feel heard,
even if I know this application
might not be enough.
Years later when I started
working more closely
with actual immigration attorneys
rather than just volunteers,
I found out that they actually
called the I-589 on its own
a skeleton application,
just the bare bones.
When a lawyer actually helps
someone apply for asylum,
something that happens
in less than four and 10
people applying from outside
the detention center and
for even fewer people
applying from inside, the
skeleton is in fleshed,
you add affidavits, expert
witness testimonies,
reports from forensic pathologies
who are able to examine
clients living bodies,
fact files of reporting on
what's called country conditions.
A fully completed asylum application
usually runs somewhere
between 300 and 500 pages,
solid bricks of paperwork,
they're stacked up high
like a defensive wall when
someone goes into court.
We in the Pro Se Clinic were
turning in the 12 flimsy pages
of the application alone,
this in itself was a strategy.
It allowed Myra to have an application in
prior to the one year filing deadline.
It gave her extra time to find an attorney
to find another means of protection,
to ensure that she's at least got
that pending asylum
application, that paperwork in
as a mean for safeguarding
against deportation for the years
it will take for that application
to wind through the system.
The text that I end up
producing for that form
is by necessity skeletal, it's
a bone chart in the desert.
The boxes provided for
answers to the questions
asked by the I-589 are small.
And the attorneys who review our files
don't recommend using the
over flow space provided.
So we're restricted to
150 words per answer,
clipped and factual,
describing the things
that have left a mark
on a single body,
but never what it is like
to live inside that body.
Asylum translation is less
like building a bridge
and more like the translation
of saintly relics.
When a saint is canonized,
they're brought up out
of their resting place,
usually somewhere where
they lived and grew up
and did their holy works and
instead brought to a place
that is the center of power.
When Constantinople, for example,
became the center of the Christian world,
a flock of holy bones was translated there
from the surrounding areas.
This legitimated the holiness
of the tibia of St. Leucadia,
the forest full of
splinters of the holy cross,
the skull of St. Cordula
but it also gave holiness
and legitimacy to the
church in Constantinople,
marking it as holy for being able
to gather holiness to itself.
When saint's bones enter church,
they're gulden and boxed up,
removed from their text of
a grave of a living person
somewhere in a community
and instead recontextualized
and presented alongside the
calcified hedge geographies
as proof of the church's power.
You don't know actually who
St. Leucadia or St. Cordula are
or who they were or what
they did or how they died.
All you know are their
bones, their holiness,
their presence proof that the
church is worth dying for.
The translation of bones serves the church
and not the stories of those interred.
The US government is
not the Catholic church
but it does require asylum
seekers to be saints.
It gathers their stories to itself,
forces them to be translated
in language and in fact,
given that they don't accept
anything other than paper files,
something which has continued to be true
through the pandemic, mailed
into their headquarters,
into their own language
and space literally.
The power here only moves in one direction
and everything done by asylum seekers,
every translation done
by them and their allies
serves only the reader, the
United States government.
The text, the presentation
of it, the imprisonment of it
within the forms boxes
away from the messiness of a real life
and into the beats of a known
and understood hedge geography,
a quiet and virtuous life
shattered by a single act of explicitly,
politically motivated
violence and escape by night,
a plea for safety, these
are meant not at all
as an expression of the
person telling the story
and entirely to satisfy
the entity processing it.
If I do my job right,
if in those 150 words
I succeed as a translator,
what the asylum seeker
I'm working with gets
is a grudging acceptance
of their humanity,
a big official rubber stamp that says
that their suffering matters,
but not much else does
about the ways in which
they have stayed alive
or lived at all, just the suffering.
A lawyer I worked with at the clinic
called it bureaucratic violence,
the carrying across of people
out of their own words,
their own language, the mutilation
of the stories they tell,
a violence I participated in,
even if it was as gentle
as I could make it.
There was however, one other
way in which the translation
I was doing was skeletal.
When you're doing literary translation,
again, it's common to talk about the ways
that you're subsumed enveloped,
given over to the shape of
someone else's language.
A literary translation project
involves making yourself
porous to the text, allowing it into you
and allowing yourself into it.
All reading, all
interactions really involve
this kind of cross pollination,
but translation also asks and
answers a different question.
When you're translating,
you're giving over room
in your brain, days of
your one single life
to the careful minute study
of someone else's work
in order that others
might have the privilege
of encountering it.
You're not only
recognizing that your voice
isn't the most important one,
but you're sinking precious
hours into that belief.
There's also a return though,
in making yourself porous,
you also make yourself expansive,
you're allowed to reach beyond yourself.
This is both different
and not when I'm translating
for asylum seekers,
even as I'm translating their stories,
I'm passing every word they say
through my own first person,
feeling a echo of what they're
telling me in my own self.
Their stories are often ones of violence
against their bodies,
stories that pass through me
as they pass through language.
I can catalog on my own body
the places where people
have shown me their scars,
turning me into a mirror,
cigarette burns on the back
of a carefully manicured hand.
The aftermath of a surgery that was itself
the aftermath of a stabbing
someone's chest and the
softness of their belly,
crisscrossed with ropes of scar
and the punctum of
stitches on either side,
old, old bullet scars
cleanly through both ankles.
An unset broken leg, and
the weight on my shoulder
of the man who used me as
a crutch for a short walk.
I don't know in my body
what it's like to be hurt
in these ways, but I carry
a record with me anyway,
because it's impossible not to.
It's very much unvogue right now
to talk about secondhand trauma,
something common among
social workers and EMTs
and anyone else whose job involves
stepping into the worst
day in people's lives
as a shadow of knowledge
that wraps around you
when you have come to
know through observation,
the depths of cruelty
that exist in the world.
Secondhand trauma is complex.
It works in many of the same ways
that firsthand trauma does,
your brain gets rewired in the same way
as your physiological
responses are the same to it.
However, secondhand trauma also
carries the shame of safety.
You're aware that you live
removed from the suffering itself,
that your reactions are
outsized for someone
who basically is just
heard about the pain,
that you're protected even if
your physiological responses
don't recognize that, why
should I find self crying
on the train rides back home?
Why does someone's story linger with me?
Take up space in my
brain night after night?
Nothing had after all
really happened to me.
Here's where secondhand trauma
does differ from first
though, I give it time,
just a little, a matter of weeks or months
and the hauling range
stops, the winds die down.
It gets quiet enough for me to work,
to put words to the things
that I saw and felt,
to find the way to bring other
people into what I'm feeling.
When I translate, I try
to make myself invisible,
in a sense I don't exist.
When I take up the weight
of someone else's story
by translating it, the
thing I carry is a ghost
and the teller is no
lighter for the mere fact
of me carrying the story alongside them.
It's in feeling the weight of the story
that I can transmit it to
you also, which is why I try
and why I try to erase
myself in the process
so that you might read someone's words
that I have translated and
be reminded of your mother
or your aunt or your sister,
your neighbors and friends
forgetting the step in the middle.
I aim to become invisible
because then this asylum seeker
is speaking directly to you
and you have no choice but to listen.
When I'm writing though,
working on this book
or on a press release or a
client profile for my day job
for this speech, this is
when I have a different goal.
You for better or worse,
recognize me is one of your own.
We share experiences, a
language, a way of reading
or thinking about the world,
that means that I've
been invited here to work
and give a talk at Yale, but
I've also however, briefly
and not experientially had
my foot in another world,
which is the world that I'm
here to translate for you.
This trauma translation,
my weaker ghost version
of the original thing
that witnessed, I'm hoping it
works like a real translation.
In the same way that translating a text
brings it to a new audience,
I want my work to bring a reality
that was previously invisible
and illegible to light.
I'm hoping it builds a bridge
to greater understanding
or rather a bridge across the gaps
when you realize that like me,
you understand so very little of anything.
I hope it's clear that
what I'm giving you is not,
cannot actually be the real thing.
I couldn't even hold
the real thing myself.
I felt it slipped through
my fingers as I tried.
It's far from Walter Benjamin's ideal
of an invisible translator,
but I'm doing the only thing I can.
I'm making myself visible.
I'm taking your hand and
walking you through it,
pointing out the places
where I've left fingers out
or omitted details, critiquing
my own translating as we go.
I can't go back to the person I was before
that church basement in
New York, before Tijuana,
before the Boston courtroom
or the prison along the Mississippi.
I can't unbecome my parents' daughter,
I can't unlearn Spanish
or unteach myself English.
And so I'm left to return
to these things in places
over and over to draw strength from them
to see the world more
clearly, to think of them
not as the facts of a
biography but as tools
with which to dismantle walls,
tools with which to
flinging open the doors
and beckon people in, thank you.
(audience applauding)
- [Woman 1] I'm wondering,
you've worked on
a lot of different kinds of translation,
are there kinds of translation
that you haven't worked on
that you would really like to explore
or things on your radar
that maybe you've worked on privately
that you hope to maybe bring
to your professional side?
I know that you have a lot
of different directions
for translation that you work on.
- Yeah, I have done a fair
amount of literary translation
on my own, but haven't
had a ton published.
I do have a book with
Fordham University Press
that I got to collaborate
with Rachel Buff,
who is an immigration historian
at the University of Milwaukee.
And the book is called
"A is for Asylum Seeker"
and it's actually a bilingual edition,
which is really great.
But beyond that, I haven't
really gotten to do
a ton of literary translation
that's been published
and edited and that I've
really got to be forced
to bring all the way to completion.
And so that's something
that I really would like to do more of.
- [Man 1] Thank you so much for that.
That was a really beautiful
and very stimulating talk.
I realize some members of the
audience may be more versed
in all of this literature than I am,
but I was just curious
if you could explain
a little bit more, the
connection you described between
modern translation theory and literature
and Christian conceptions of suffering
and the connection between those two.
And I found that fascinating.
- Yeah, so I think a lot of
times when you are looking at
really early translation theory,
a lot of the really like Saint Jerome,
who was the first guy to
translate the Bible into Latin
in its entirety, you're
really seeing a lot of things
that are struggling with
how can we take this text
that we recognize as
being completely divine,
completely inviolable
and then translate it?
Is that not removing it from its sanctity?
Is it not carrying it away from that
in a lot of the same
ways that we talk about
translations as being
less correct versions
of the original text or
adulterated versions.
There's a quote, I think from Servantis,
who describes a translation
is a back of an embroidery actually,
and showing all the
seams and the ugly sides.
And so when you are
referring to the original
in this inviolable light,
because it's divine,
because it's perfect, even
when you're talking about
something other than a scriptural text,
you're still giving it this
authority and this divinity
that gets really complicated
and gets really muddy
when what you're talking
about is someone's account
of suffering that was
extracted from them willingly
in order so that they
might fill out this form.
And I think that Christian
scripture especially is really,
there's a lot of emphasis on suffering,
in particular being pure and being divine
and being one of the ways
that we attain holiness,
like just through the Christ story alone
is a pretty clear example of that.
And so when you kind
of lay things together,
things get really, really muddy
if you're looking at
this suffering as holy
when we should really be
regarding it as anything but.
- [Woman 2] Is this
on? (Woman 2 chuckling)
I wondered whether the words
that you just shared with us,
your speech today is in
the book that's coming out.
- Yeah.
- [Woman 2] Because I wanna share it
with some other interpreters that I know.
- Oh, wonderful.
(Alejandra chuckling)
- [Woman 2] And I don't
know if it's separate
or in the book.
- It's in the book, but I
was copying and pasting a lot
from different sections of the book.
There's some things in here
that don't appear in the book.
Like the book is, it's a Venn diagram
that's very closely overlapped
but there's still some
stuff outside of it,
but I think this is going to
be on YouTube later, so yeah.
- [Man 2] Hi, thank you so much for coming
and speaking with us.
You cited early Walter Benjamin's,
"The Task of the Translator"
and one of his core arguments
in that text is that it's not just merely
that the translator's role
is to translate a work
from a language A to language B,
but that that act of translation in fact
changes both those languages
and the work itself.
And I actually am a
student at the law school
and I recently had the opportunity
to do intake interviews
for asylum seekers.
And so I'm curious having gone through
that translation process
myself in a smaller form,
what is your process of
translation as well as navigating
your ethical obligations of the translator
when your trying to take
what these clients of yours
are trying to share with you
and as you translate that
and change it in a separate language
and as well into the box that
basically the US government
wants you to be able to
fit their narrative in
and also trying to create
a compelling narrative
for the government.
- Yeah, so this was something
that I really struggled with
and I still really struggle
with as I'm in my day job,
I am the Communications Coordinator
for the National Immigrant Justice Center.
I end up interviewing a lot of people.
And while they get to tell
somewhat expanded stories
of and about themselves for
things like the media and stuff,
there's still always
sensitivities around the case
that we want to be like,
okay, I know this feels important for you
but you cannot share this in a wider venue
in case it impacts your case
or people are going to read
this in a different way
than what you are wanting
to share about yourself.
And then it's also really
hard to actually get someone's
full informed consent to do the
translation and storytelling
that you're doing, because you're like,
this is what I need from you,
this is what the US
government needs from you.
And I know that what feels
important to you about you story
is maybe not the same things
as what this other entity
feels is important.
And so the best answer, the
best workaround I've found
is to just read back,
retranslate whatever I've
come up with back into Spanish
for them and be like, okay,
here's what I have for you,
I know it's not going
to say the whole thing,
I know it's not how you
would tell your story
because I've heard you tell your story
and this is not how you tell it,
but I'm going to give
you back what I've done.
And tell me if there's something
that you want to change,
keeping in mind that we have
all of these bullet points
that we need to hit in order
to make this the strongest case
that we can for you.
And so it's just about
talking back and forth
as much as possible and being like,
here's what I'm hearing from you,
here's what I need to
share with the government,
here's what the government
is going to know about you eventually,
or what this journalist is going to know
or what we can share with this journalist
and what would be better if
we don't talk to about them
or whatever's going on.
- [Woman 3] Yeah, I
wanna continue on that.
Because as you were speaking,
there was this incredible
suspense you created in your talk.
And I was imagining the form in my mind.
I mean, I could see the
paper and I was imagining
how in the world, how
Miriam's story came out.
And I started thinking about
narrative and about restraint
and the kind of restraint you have to use.
I mean, you've answered it a little
but I guess what I wonder
is say in your book,
are you gonna include some of those forms?
- Oh, that's a good question.
I don't currently have
any in there right now.
I do have some of the conversations
that I was describing of like,
okay, I'm gonna read you your story back
or like, let's have this
conversation about what's going on.
And there are also all different
kinds of ways that people
respond to having to tell this story.
I've sat there with people
who are just telling joke
after joke after joke
of horrifying things that
are happening to them.
I've heard of people who just
stare down at their hands,
do a monotone, I'm going
to get this all out,
it's going to come out once and that's it,
no questions we're done here.
I've had people who cry
through the whole thing.
There's just such a variety of ways
that people encounter this questioning
that again you're like, I
want to be able to take this
and like show the government
this person is so altered
by having passed through this.
And their storytelling is so altered
by having gone through this experience
and there's just no
way to get that across.
And some people end up
eventually getting to go to court
and having their hearing
and being able to testify
on their own behalf
but that's pretty rare.
- [Woman 3] Yeah, it's
heartbreaking that there's no room
for storytelling and yet
you need to move somebody,
somebody on the other end
is reading and being moved
or reading between the lines.
Yeah, thank you.
- [Woman 4] Thank you so much
for sharing this story with us.
I am wondering where your relationship
ends with each of these clients.
Does it stop after they fill out this form
or do you continue to help
them through their process
and get updates on
whether their application
was approved or not?
- That really depends on what
I'm working on them with.
So when I was working
at the Pro Se Clinic,
it was very much like, you
have your paperwork go file it.
We were not attorneys, we
were not really qualified
to help them through any of the
other stages of the process.
And so every once in a while
someone would come back
and be like, this happened,
or this is going on.
I do have a lot more
contact with the folks
that I work with now
at the National Immigrant Justice Center,
because I do work with
a lot of attorneys who,
there have been times, I actually got to,
there's an AP story about this
that I did the translation for
but we had a client named
Alex who had been in detention
for a really, really long time.
He was a gay man and he had been,
the guards there were just
kind of pushing him around
and being really mean to him.
And I said that they were gonna
let him go and they didn't.
And there was all this push
pull going on with that.
And then there got to a
point where he was like,
"I'm done, I wanna talk to a reporter,
let's get this set up."
And so I was able to work on interpreting
through that with him.
And then a couple months ago actually,
he got out and got reunited
with his boyfriend,
he's living very happily.
And so it's very occasionally
that I get to hear the
endpoint of someone's story.
But especially now that I'm working
with a legal aid organization,
very often they are
good ending to stories.
And that's really, really nice.
I think we're set, oh,
Hailey's coming back.
(Alejandra laughing)
- [Woman 5] Time for one
more, oh Hailey has one.
- Hailey has one.
(Alejandra chuckling)
- [Hailey] So I know that the
book that you're working on
right now is coming out
and I'm curious in terms of
how much of that includes your
experience with immigration
versus translation theory versus,
I know you touched on some
of the Christianity roots
of translation and how do you balance
how much you include of those pieces?
- By having a very good editor.
(audience laughing)
I gotta say that a lot of my early drafts
are pretty heavily lopsided
in one direction or another
and they're like, "Okay, hold on,
you have to bring this other thread back
or you have to talk about
this a little more."
I also know that I know
a lot about this stuff
but sometimes forget
that other people don't.
And so I am lucky enough
to work with a really
fantastic agent who is like,
"I don't know what this
means, you need to explain
what a credible fear
interview is a little better
or something like that."
And so I've been really, really lucky
to work with other people who
have been fantastic readers
and asking me good questions
to make sure that
everything's well balanced
because that's not
always my first impulse.
- [Woman 6] Well, we wish
you just huge success
with this important
book and thank you again
for sharing your story and
the story of your clients.
- Thank you so much.
(audience applauding)